hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm just want to make
sure everyone was aware the tomorrow
starts the world rapid and blitz chess
championship in Dubai as you can see
from this list right here we have the
top players in the entire world that's
going to be playing here going to be
some fantastic chest I'm going to have
full coverage I'm going to be doing
commentary on as many games as I think I
humanly possibly can over the next six
days so definitely want to make sure
that you stay tuned for all that
coverage also want you guys to know for
this tournament this is one of my
favorite tournaments of the year I went
out and got a new mic I got a new
popscreen so I've got some better
equipment I think I've gotten some
positive feedback so far from friends
and family about the mic but wanted to
see what you guys think of the new sound
quality of the videos because this is
what I'm going to be using for the
tournament so let me know some feedback
as far as what you guys think of a sound
and then stay tuned tomorrow for full
coverage of the world rapid and blitz
championship